はい、という訳で今日の動画はですね、
ちょっとある物を使ってやっていきたいと思います。
こちら
う゛ぉううぉううぉ！
はい、という訳で今回はこちら
この中に入っている物が肝心です。
あれ？
肝心の何が入っているのかっていうのを、ちょっと見ていきましょう。
あ～これこれこれ。
これですよ、これこれこれこれ。
これですよ。
今回使うのはこちら。
まぁ梱包材とはいわゆる、
なんか物とかをこう、配達とか運ぶときに
ぶつかったときの衝撃とかを吸収するために、
一緒に入れられることがあります。
これですね
中に空気が入ってるやつで、
すごい頑丈です。
大事なものがこう、あると。
睾丸とかね...
梱包材を入れておくと、
衝撃が来ても、威力を吸収するんで、
壊れなくなると。
今回はこちらの梱包材を、
・・・。
すまない！！
ちょっと多すぎるので場所変更！
ちょっと数えてみた結果、
5箱合わせると、
ちょっと全部開けていきましょう。
うわっ、まだあるか。
おっけーい！
うぉーい！
みんな、聞いてくれ。
ちょっと予想より、たくさんあるな...
梱包材といえば、安全を守る。
衝撃を吸収するので、衝撃が与えられても安全なんです。
私はそこに、
感動を覚えた。
この梱包材1000個を私の体に全部巻いて、
史上最強に、
もう、多分世界で一番安全でしょう。
ではいこーう！！
ではいこう！
はい、という訳で完成しました。
これこそが、梱包材1000個を身に纏った最強のボディースーツ。
この私にかかれば、どんな強い攻撃も余裕でガードできる。
ハッハッハッ
ちょっとこのボディで、
いろんな攻撃に耐えてみましょう。
痛くない。
いけるぞこれ。
うおっ
痛くない！
えっ、痛くないよ！
よし来い。
おーっ
痛くな（ｒｙ
スリー、トゥー、ワン、
あーっ、あーっ！
あれ？どうすればいい？
あーっ
お願いします！